toujours en corse le tribunal
administratif de bastia a rejeté
finalement la plainte de deux malades
atteints d'un cancer de la thyroïde de
malades qui pointe du doigt ce qu'ils
dénomment un mensonge d'état pour la
maladie serait directement liée au
passage du nuage de tchernobyl au dessus
de l'île il y à 21 ans
reportage nathalie sapina sylvain
gauthier c'est sous le soleil de bastia
que charles lacourarie a grandi sans
souci notable jusqu'à ses 24 ans on lui
découvre alors un concert rare de la
thyroïde côté donc d'une oreille une
autre c'était très dur à vivre et c'est
toujours dur à vivre aujourd'hui je suis
condamné entre guillemets à prendre des
médicaments à vie et je suis bi
une fois par an des
contrôles médicaux toujours sur paris
donc toujours quelques semaines avant
cette angoisse d'autant plus dure à
supporter qu'il en est convaincu la
cause de son cancer c'est le nuage de
tchernobyl qui a survolé la corse en
1986 et contaminer les légumes et les
produits laitiers qu'il a mangé à
l'époque il avait ne vaut l'état
français n'a pas interdit la
consommation de ces produits qui
concentrent la radioactivité
on nous a rien dit on nous a caché la
vérité quand ce nuage et a traversé
l'europe pour nous a dit que en france
il n'y avait rien alors que dans
d'autres pays européens des précautions
des prises le tribunal a rejeté sa
requête
mais il va faire appel contre l'état
avec les mêmes arguments
si vous aviez dit la vérité je serais
allé à la pharmacie prendre des cachets
diodes j'aurais éviter de manger du lait
de boire du lait de manger de la viande
d'aller chercher des champignons d'aller
dans la garrigue et toutes ces
précautions font que peut-être j'aurais
aujourd'hui une situation au niveau de
la santé une situation saine alors y at
il plus de cancers de la thyroïde en
corse
aucune étude ne le démontrent mais pour
les médecins corse il n'y a pas de doute
il soigne plus de maladies de la
thyroïde même non cancéreuses
la demande est très forte de
consultation pour ce type de pathologie
c'est de l'ordre de 60% alors qu'un
cabinet d'endocrinologie normal enfin
normal je dirais
habituel représente à une activité
d'environ 30%
21 ans après le nuage de tchernobyl n'en
finit pas d'inquiéter
plusieurs études sont actuellement
lancés en corse d'autant qu'une plainte
au pénal déposée par six ans victime de
toute la france en 2001 est toujours en
cours d'instruction